it can be tough to figure out what's a
stream next and Netflix has vast library
but don't worry from incredible
underrated gems to timeless favorites
that you haven't thought about in years
we've rounded up some of the best movies
on Netflix right now some filmmakers
fall flat on their faces when they make
their first movie but Duncan Jones is
one of the few directors who more than
deliver the goods with his feature film
debut titled simply moon Jones's debut
is not just a staggeringly assured first
outing it's also one of the best sci-fi
films produced in the 21st century set
almost entirely on the lunar surface the
film follows a contract worker who spend
the duration of a three-year contract in
near total isolation on the cusp of
fulfilling his obligations and heading
home to see his wife and daughter somes
intensely isolated existence takes a
surprising turn when he finds himself
too victim of a near-fatal mining
accident Sam Rockwell delivers densely
layered work that turns what's
essentially a one-man show into a
complex heartbreaking character study in
the psychiatry of self solitude and
science run amok this stylized little
film simply must be seen to be believed
it's hard to believe that over 20 years
of passed since David Fincher terrorized
the movie going public with this
brutalist tale of biblical morality when
a mark but somehow the decades haven't
dulled the soul-crushing impact of
inches allowing detective tale in fact
it's possible that 7 may even be more
disturbing today than it was when it hit
theaters in 1995 the film follows a
rookie detective and his veteran partner
on the hunt for a vicious serial killer
who's using the seven deadly sins as
motive the murders figure prominently in
sevens nightmarish narrative so before
you press play please know that this
film is not for the weak of heart saying
look I know he's probably dancing around
7 is a source of movie that seeps into
your skin I've never really scrubs clean
that's generally a good thing because as
difficult as Fincher's film can be to
sit through its a genuinely unsettling
crime thriller crafted with undeniable
skill and uncompromising vision and once
you watch it you'll never see a FedEx
commercial the same way again
bring an old friend some movies aim to
dazzle the eye others to touch the heart
but others to move the mind the best
films do all of those things at once an
GML del Toro has essentially specialized
in making movies that do exactly that of
all the directors features a few feel
more personal or visionary than his 2006
masterpiece Pan's Labyrinth hoping to
evade the violence of the Spanish Civil
War a philia a bookish preteen and her
mother are whisked off to an isolated
estate along the way she meets a fairy
that takes her to a centuries-old faun a
mythical creature who informs her philia
she's a princess and can claim her
throne only if she survives three
harrowing feats of bravery del Toro
pulls inspired performances from his
cast conjures images of shrilling as
they are terrifying and finds untold
depths of beauty with fantastical
landscapes verse making a film that
dazzles the eye touches the heart and
moves the mind in ways most movies
cannot fathom
well there isn't really much we can say
about Christopher Nolan's comic-book
masterpiece hasn't already been said
it's worth noting that people still talk
about the Dark Knight like it hit
theaters last week and still Revere the
film as a comic adaptation that forever
changed the game came a limited edition
two hundred and ninety nine dollar Dark
Knight DVD with bonus footage special
commentary autograph the good news is
that the folks and Netflix have
apparently recognized that and have we
added the Dark Knight to their long list
of offerings but means you can once
again bear witness to the pulse-pounding
caper that introduces the marvelous
Joker to Gotham you can once again we
live the heartache and heroism that
drives a dark night to perform
increasingly death-defying deeds you can
once again watch Gordon squirm through
the rights and wrongs sides of the law
and watch the unexpected birth of
two-face in tow and you can once again
give yourself over to the Batman movie
that we needed and deserve
Quentin Tarantino's eighth film the
hateful eight takes place in the
aftermath of the Civil War we're
introduced to eight people who get
snowed in at a roadside pitstop and as a
title asserts none of them are
particularly savory characters there's a
lot of talking a lot of bloodshed and a
lot of Tarantino nests all around as a
Western sure the hateful eight is no
fistful of dollars but as Nerdist very
effectively argues it's not a Western at
all it's a horror movie for starters as
Tarantino himself explained it was most
directly inspired by John Carpenter's
1982 body horror film the thing on top
of that the musical score includes
tracks from the thing and The Exorcist
to deliberately adding to the sense that
monsters are lurking even if they turn
out to be human after all now I am
calling you a liar
senior Bob during the 90s Wesley Snipes
tried like crazy to get a big screen
version of Marvel's black panther into
production according to The Hollywood
Reporter it never quite came together
but a couple of decades later CGI
technology advanced enough to bring the
radical tech centric world of Wakanda to
life that's just what director Ryan
Coogler accomplishes and black panther
delivering a vividly realized vision of
the
no nation that appears advanced beyond
our wildest dreams
what also feels like human beings
actually live there koogler also
ingeniously uses a setting as a plot
device in a Shakespearean tale of Palace
politics tribal traditions and
ideological conflicts he populates that
narrative with richly developed
characters and propels it forward with
some of the most electrifying action
sequences the marvel cinematic universe
has ever seen
but he also delivers a politically
subversive on the way is what qualifies
Black Panther as one of the best Marvel
movies to date
Robert Eggers haunting folk tale the
witch is one of the films that helped
set the bar for current horror trends
aigis masterfully executed chiller wild
audiences at the 2015 sundance film
festival and actually made a few bugs in
its initial theatrical release even if
it didn't exactly set the box office on
fire behind marvelous critical buzz and
equally solid word-of-mouth the witch
has more than found its audience after
the fact with many hailing it as one of
the best horror films of the decade
Eggers film follows a
seventeenth-century family whose
devoutly puritanical existence falls
apart under the weight of unspeakable
tragedies which may or may not be
influenced by an evil lurking in a
nearby forest acres film is a bleak
intensely Atmospheric study in gothic
Americana that features a star-making
turn from our near Taylor joy it's the
sort of film that you simply have to see
to believe
2016's hush is definitely a movie you
can't miss the premise is simple Maddie
a deaf and mute author is staying in an
isolated house deep in the Alabama woods
when a masked killer appears at a window
well that concept could easily devolve
into another one of the male suspense
flick push has no problem up in the
thrill factor with deft camerawork and
will ending suspense and the truly
amazing performance from actress kate
siegel she portrays mary is strong
capable and intelligent a breath of
fresh air for a female role in a horror
movie
of course the sound design in her she's
top-notch director Mike Flanagan it uses
Manny's disability to keep the constant
threat of danger looming he never gets
gimmicky with his portrayal of Maddie's
deafness giving us exactly as much as we
need to feel the fear of never knowing
what's behind us with 1998 The Truman
Show a funny man Jim Carrey's oddball
Ayers was stripped away to reveal a
serious actor who could be both
and sincere he stars as Truman Burbank a
quiet everyday guy who just so happens
to be the star of the world's largest
reality show the catch
Truman doesn't know his on a show since
birth every moment of his life has been
filmed and broadcast to the world all
his neighbors and friends even his wife
are actors on the show he's never left
his hometown because his hometown is a
giant film set good morning oh and in
case I don't see you good afternoon good
evening and good night
couple carries remarkable depth a
beautiful direction and a heartfelt
story and The Truman Show is easily one
of the best films of the late 90s and
one of the best on Netflix right now so
here's the formula for the 2015 film
room you take a room you put two people
in it and then you center it all around
the thrilling emotional struggle that
builds until the entire audience is
questioning everything they thought they
knew about life a family and loved ones
room starts going it never slows down
the beauty of the film comes and
questionably from brie Larson and Jacob
Tremblay who played the mother and son
locked in a room they visited
periodically by a mysterious man with
employers and the rest of the time they
occupied themselves by playing games
telling stories and for Larsen's
character try not to focus on the hell
of spending the rest of their lives in
the room cake
no check let's try a bite a bit it's
their bond with all its ups and downs
that anchors a movie and drives
everything that happens if you've been
on the fence about room keep it up now
and don't worry it won't disappoint
director Michel Gondry and writer
Charlie Kaufman teamed up for 2006 is
Eternal Sunshine of the spotless mind
equal parts quirky sci-fi farce and
heartfelt romantic drama the film
follows a man and woman who each have
memories of their relationship
scientifically removed from their brain
after a rocky breakup in lesser hands it
may have been silly with Gondry and
Kaufman guiding the narrative eternal
sunshine instead plays out as a
near-flawless mix of genres that
seamlessly blends Gondry's lo-fi
craftsmanship with Kaufman's grounded
insight for romantic fable
anchored by powerfully performances
eternal sunshine is a bold funny and the
secretive little film the manages to be
wildly romantic
and anti-romantic an equal measure and
somehow satisfies emotionally on both
fronts one of the more unsung films in a
24 slide up is a harrowing mind bender
of a thriller anime starring Jake
Gyllenhaal and a revelatory door
performance the film follows a quiet man
who in wittingly finds his doppelganger
and proceeds to have a full-blown crisis
of identity along the way the pair's
lives become a tangled web of Secrets
obsessions and lust but threatens to
upend each of their existences enemy is
an artistically and narrative ly
ambitious film worthy the sort of
in-depth examination a typically
reserved for great works of literature
is one of the most hauntingly ambiguous
trailers you'll ever see
with a bold blend of stark visuals and
the near suffocating sense of
atmospheric tread check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
loop of videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]